ya estamos listos para llegar a la parte
más sustancial de evaluar esta integral
y poder expresarla en términos de una
integral doble de los parámetros y lo
primero que haré es expresar esta parte
de aquí que es esencialmente la que
contiene al vector normal unitario y
vamos a reescribir lo usando los
parámetros bajo las bajo los cuales
parametrizados nuestra superficie ese
entonces vamos a reescribir nds porque n
de s también sabemos que lo podemos
escribir como un vector de esta forma
como la diferencial de un vector la
diferencial de s que esencialmente está
tomando un vector que apunta en la misma
dirección del vector normal unitario
pero que no tiene norma 1 este este
compadre de aquí lo podemos expresar
como ese ere que es la derivada de ese
respecto de r cruz la derivada de ese
respecto de theta la derivada parcial
hay que multiplicar por las
diferenciales de los parámetros es decir
de teta de r
ok este de teta y de r los podemos
cambiar de orden eso dependerá de qué
tan fácil o no es calcular la integral
que nos va a resultar ok entonces vamos
a ver también que necesitamos orientar
muy bien nuestra superficie y para eso
vamos a regresar nos al dibujo de aquí
arriba porque hacia donde apunta el ese
ere ese ere es la la derivada
direccional al aumentar r pero se
aumenta r pues esencialmente nos estamos
alejando del centro ok y ahora bien
simplemente es eta st está que es este
de aquí bueno pues cambia según como
estamos girando entonces no es fácil no
es difícil más bien convencerse de que
esto apunta de esta forma y eso es por
cómo está girando esta superficie o más
bien la curva
ok como gira el ángulo esencialmente
respecto al cual estamos parametrizado y
por lo tanto pues cuando calculamos el
producto cruz este vector no normal
apunta justamente como estamos pensando
en este dibujo entonces ya que tenemos
esto lo que vamos a hacer es lo
siguiente vamos a calcular quién es ese
ere cruz ese teta vamos a calcular eso
en adelante y que la forma que mejor me
me gusta es cuando tenemos una lo
podemos hacer de forma con con el
determinante no entonces ese ere cruz
ese teta pues lo podemos expresar como
un determinante en donde en esta primera
parte ponemos
y ponemos a j y luego ponemos a cada ok
y luego en esta parte vamos a poner las
derivadas parciales
ok respecto de r&d x 67 entonces la
derivada parcial de x respecto de r
simplemente es coseno de teta vamos a
ponerlo simplemente coseno de teta la
derivada de jr respecto de ere es seno
de teta ya tenemos aquí seno de teta y
la derivada de zeta respecto de r pues
simplemente es menos seno de teta ok al
derivar este 12 anula y seno de teta
pues es una constante para fines de
derivar respecto de r
vamos a calcular este determinante de
aquí y ahora vamos a ver a derivar
respecto a este está cuál es la derivada
de x respecto de teta pues es r por la
derivada de coseno que es menos seno y
entonces tenemos menos ere seno de teta
ok es la primera parte luego la derivada
de ye respecto de teta pues es r por la
derivada de seno que es coseno entonces
es r coseno de teta y luego es la
derivada de zeta respecto de teta que es
menos r por la derivada de seno que es
coseno entonces es menos r coseno dt
está ok entonces esto a quien va a ser
igual bueno pues simplemente ponemos a y
ok vamos a tomarnos primero esta entrada
y por vamos a utilizar otro color
entonces es el sub determinante de esta
parte que es menos r
jose no detecta por seno de teta ok es
esta diagonal multiplicada menos
este producto que es el recogen o beteta
por menos seno de teta pero como es
menos nos queda más r
jose no de teta seno de teta y estas
partes son las que me fascinan porque si
se dan cuenta esto se cancela y se hace
0 entonces realmente no tenemos parte en
y vamos a ver qué pasa con con j
porque al tomar j aquí tenemos que
considerar - j que multiplica ya este
sub determinante que que queda de quitar
esta columna está este renglón perdón y
esta segunda columna que nos queda
coseno beteta por - r coseno beteta que
es menos r
coseno cuadrado de teta y luego menos
menos el producto de este por éste que
es menos r s no detecta por menos de
teta menos por menos es más y nos queda
r seno cuadrado de teta que si se dan
cuenta esto lo vamos a poder simplificar
pero vamos vamos haciéndolo por pasitos
y luego tengo que sumar ahora tomando el
término en k
de que multiplica a este sub
determinante que es esta diagonal que es
r coseno cuadrado de teta
de teta y aquí es menos por menos crs no
beteta porción a beteta entonces nos
queda más r seno cuadrado de teta seno
cuadrado de teta entonces si se dan
cuenta de en esta parte de acá arriba yo
por distribuir el menos y aquí tengo más
más y más es decir el menos que
multiplica cada uno de los sumandos y
tengo r que multiplica a coseno cuadrado
de teta más seno cuadrado de teta pero
cocino cuadrado más seno cuadrado es la
la identidad más fundamental que tenemos
esto simplemente es uno entonces r por
uno simplemente es r del lado de abajo
tenemos esencialmente lo mismo porque
tenemos r por coseno cuadrado de teta
más seno cuadrado de teta que nuevamente
por la identidad trigonométricas más
sencilla que conocemos esto es uno que
es lo que nos quedó pues qué
s cruz s t está simplemente es j que
multiplica a r
mas k que multiplica también a r
entonces vamos escribiendo esto porque
esta integral de aquí finalmente como
nos queda es de la siguiente forma
tenemos la integral
ok la integral del rotacional de nuestro
campo efe
punto nuestro vector normal por de s que
ya lo calculamos que esto es simplemente
déjenme lo escribo bien es rj más cerca
rk y aquí es de teta de r pero te está
entre key que se mueve pues teta se
mueve entre 0 y 2 pi y la r se mueve
entre 0 y 1 porque todo esto era el
círculo unitario entonces lo voy a dejar
ahí en el próximo vídeo vamos a calcular
el rotacional df y quizás en ese mismo
vídeo si tenemos suficiente tiempo
llegamos a la última parte